[Music]
you do want to be inspired from the very
beginning
creative collaboration was happening
since the day we met the way fernando
starts his process by sketching and the
way i start my process by draping or
cutting fabric but we're ultimately
ending up at the same place
i would definitely recommend latching on
to people that are strong enough to push
you but also vulnerable enough to listen
to your ideas
what i learned about how to be a leader
from oscar was he was always having fun
we're always laughing i think that's
very important in a creative environment
this class is not just for fashion
students but also for people who want to
start a business with a partner in any
industry in this class we're going to
teach you how laura and i work together
we're going to do fittings how we design
a collection how you sketch how we build
a team how i trade i think no matter
what you just need to be comfortable to
be around somebody who can challenge you
i think those honest conversation makes
us good partners
when we both started we didn't
understand what it was like to launch a
brand and we realized that designing was
perhaps 50 of the time i get inspired a
lot by just random people walking by it
could be like a picture of a really cute
dog or a hot guy on a beach that i saw
if you were to start your own business
you should really understand who you are
as a person and find someone who can do
stuff that you can't do
that
might be the next runway i'm laura kim
i'm fernando garcia and this is
masterclass
you